what's going on guys this is rob and one
of my little guilty pleasures here right
best kept secrets when it comes to dc
comics is the earth 3 crime syndicate
limited series right it's only six
issues long and in fact it just finished
but in the back of each of these issues
are basically the origins of the
different members of the crime syndicate
right
uh ultraman superwoman all those kind of
characters and this one is emerald
knight but here's the funny thing about
this
is that if you guys are familiar with
the crime syndicate you guys know the
green lantern
is actually hal jordan instead this
starts off with jon stewart which really
begs the question how is it that the
the green lantern ring the emerald night
ring as it's called goes from jon
stewart to hal jordan and i'm sure we'll
find that out over the course of the
series but the cool thing about this
is that with jon stewart himself as most
of you guys know he's the the kind of
law and order guy right jon stewart's
not the guy to get involved in different
crimes or or crazy situations or
anything like that
right this guy is former military and he
seemingly always kind of does the right
thing
except for when he blows up a world
right then that definitely wasn't the
right thing to do but regardless of the
situation
jon stewart's one of these guys where
you want him in your corner
with earth 3 one of the things to keep
in mind for those of you guys who are
new to comics
earth 3 is basically a universe where
everything is kind of topsy-turvy
so the good guys are bad guys the bad
guys are good guys people are largely
self-interested
and they don't really care about other
people so like a majority of humanity
here in the real world
for all you cynics out there but uh but
the story of jon stewart is really cool
right so
initially this picks up in coast city
about five months before the start of
the
crime syndicate story and you initially
pick up with jon stewart
uh you know as a cop who's there with
his daughter liza now this is also kind
of a big change too
is it jon stewart as an ex-military guy
usually when you think of like a cop in
the green lanterns you think of guy
gardner right you don't really think of
jon stewart but it's one of these cool
little things now in the midst of this
you know as he's kind of talking to his
daughter and she's kind of like you know
everybody's staring at my crutches and
that kind of thing feeling very very uh
self-conscious about the surgery she'd
gone to the injuries she'd sustained
different things like that the reality
is jon stewart really kind of reminds us
of the version that we know from the
main dc universe
when he tells her like here's the thing
right things are different now for you
but at the end of the day remember who
you are right don't let other people get
to you at the end of the day that's
really kind of what's going on
you know don't let them bother you don't
let them get to you just kind of do your
own thing
in the middle of all that there's a kind
of a scuffle across the street
and when one of the guys is like there's
a cop over there then the person who's
doing the scuffling right the the
criminal we can call him that looks over
and realizes jon stewart and says oh no
no don't worry about him he owes my dad
right like this guy owes my dad money so
you know it's it's not a great big huge
deal at that point
jon stewart freaks out now because of
the fact that this is such a
short uh comic right three or four pages
there isn't really a whole lot given to
us in terms of extreme detail but we can
kind of fill in the blanks on our own
right that one of the things that he
talks about here is that when it comes
to the bad guys getting a hold of the
good guys and getting good guys to do
bad things
that it's not usually with like bullets
and bombs right sometimes that happens
right sometimes it happens when you know
you have have
villains criminals what have you who
just you know show up guns blazing
and just kind of spray everything down
but the reality is that in this
situation
in john's case it was that he made a
mistake that when his daughter
needed surgery that he didn't have the
money to do it on his own so he
basically ended up taking money from
what seems to be a crime boss and that
he paid him back right he did whatever
it is he needed to do and then he paid
the guy back his debts clear but the
reality is
as far as you know those members of the
criminal underworld who are familiar
with the situation go
jon stewart owes this guy right so it's
one of these things where he's kind of
tainted right and it's just gonna follow
him around or seems to follow him around
forever now
unlike jon stewart as we know him where
he's a lot more controlled he's a lot
more reserved that he's very very
methodical as opposed to being more
emotional like hal jordan right you know
quick to fly off the handle in the case
of somebody like kyle rainer where he's
he's a lot more confined in that way
here he just loses it right he
immediately starts attacking this guy
and again that's the nature of earth 3
that the characters are essentially
their opposites right as we know them in
terms of personality in terms of their
powers as far as how they get them the
role they play
in the superhero landscape and so he
just like literally starts attacking
this guy and he's like you don't control
me you don't own me
none of that stuff right nobody owns me
but at the end of the day the biggest
issue that he sees himself kind of
falling into here
is that he's kind of becoming that
villain right becoming that version of
himself that he simply didn't
necessarily want to be now
one of the things that's kind of murky
about earth 3 and it's one of the things
that dc's kind of
waxed and waned on going all the way
back to the pre-crisis days
uh you know in the the post-crisis
landscape and even during like the new
52
is that the nature in which people end
up becoming their
villainous or evil selves in earth 3
changes right that if you go and you
read the old
the old pre-crisis stuff they were just
naturally that way right it's just
inherently the way they were
in more recent years it's been one of
those things where it's just kind of
like given the nature of the universe
their personalities
naturally gravitate to being that way so
it really kind of shifts and changes
based on what era of story you're
talking about but ultimately his
daughter witnesses him losing control
and absolutely pummeling this guy now he
doesn't beat him to death right he just
beats the hell out of him if for
anything then to send a message
when suddenly he's met by the arrival of
the emerald knight ring now again
in earth 3 instead of it being called
the green lantern ring it's the emerald
night ring and so when jon stewart's met
by the arrival of this thing it's not
how we normally expect right like you
know such and such you have the ability
to overcome great fear
welcome to the green lantern court
instead it's jon stewart you will join
the ranks of the emerald knights just
appears here and says you're going to
join our ranks and the reason for that
is that in the crime syndicate landscape
and the earth 3 universe the way it's
given to us the green lanterns seem to
be more of like a paramilitary force
right they're not really a peacekeeping
force they almost fall directly in line
with what you would expect the sinestro
corps to be
from the main dc universe now one of the
funny things about this
is that this is all uncharted waters we
never got the origin of the green
lanterns themselves in terms of how they
came into existence
in the the crime syndicate universe the
closest we got was during sam humphreys
green lanterns when he basically ended
up learning that power ring which was
essentially possessed by a portion
of the spirit vulthum the first lantern
was basically that spirit of wolfhoom
from an alternate universe that was
basically trying to find a way
traveling through the multiverse to
prevent the destruction of his own
universe he ultimately failed but along
the way he put a portion of his soul
inside of a ring which became the power
ring from earth 3. that's the most we
ever got right so we've never really
seen an instance where a person's been
bonded to a green lantern ring in earth
3 how the whole process works you
basically just had hal jordan right who
showed up during forever evil and that
was it
that's really all you got which i still
feel like we should cover forever evil
somewhere along the line because we
never covered that story from dc comics
and there are a lot of great dc stories
that we should cover but the important
thing here is that when he when this
ring kind of has a conversation with
john which is not really normal that
john's just kind of like no like like
get back right and this thing's like i
will be your power ring
you will create law and order and when
the response of john is i don't want
power right i don't want to owe anybody
the response to the ring is no you must
understand my
power is free to use right this is an
honor and so it's kind of nuts because
in the midst of that this this
guy right this son of this mob boss kind
of wakes up and says like when my father
hears about this he's gonna kill you
and he's gonna kill your daughter right
now the reality of this and you talk to
anybody who's a parent right if you're a
parent who wouldn't
beg borrow steal and kill for your kid
you're no measure of a parent at all and
that's there's no arguing that point and
so in the face of that
the whole idea of jon stewart is then
i'll do whatever it takes to protect my
child right i'll do whatever it takes to
protect my
my daughter and you know kind of protect
himself as well and so ultimately the
ring tells them you have to protect your
daughter
this guy's telling you you're both gonna
die if you let him leave
so like take my ring save your daughter
save yourself kill this guy
and that's exactly what jon does jon
kills this guy in order to keep his
family safe now the funny thing about
this and what he was talking about with
the idea of a slippery slope and it's
something that i've never really agreed
on we'll talk about why here in a second
that ultimately he ends up incinerating
this guy
the ring kind of chimes in and says the
world's better off without him which it
is and then the ring says there's always
more evil jon it simply won't stop and
so ultimately it says to serve and to
protect
isn't that the oath you took we can do
that and more jon take my power
as your own and become the emerald
knight and so following that he becomes
like this pretty extreme guy
basically incinerating virtually any
evil that he comes across now the
reality of this is i don't really
believe in the argument of the slippery
slope because that implies that you have
no self-control
it implies that you're that you have
that you you lack the ability
to make intelligent and rational
decisions and that essentially any
action you take
following that is not really your fault
right it's just a slippery slope i mean
you just end up kind of falling down
this path
that's nonsense right as a human being
you have the ability to decide what you
will
and will not do at any given point in
time you can literally stop what you're
doing
and ask the question is this logical is
it reasonable is it for the greater good
right like is it legitimately for the
greater good you know it does it's not
one of these things where like your
perception of the world is forever
tainted
and you will never ever ever ever be
able to do a good
thing in your life it's one of those
things where like it's it's it doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense to me i
never really understood the slippery
slope argument i mean i'm kind of
curious let me know down in the comments
section if the slippery slope argument
is something you guys are in support of
but
again this is just a really short three
or four page origin story not a whole
lot going there uh and it just kind of
gives us the origin of how it is
that the earth 3 crime syndicate version
of jon stewart ended up becoming the
emerald knight right and there's each
you know each one of these has like
these little backup features you know
where you learn about the origins of
what is essentially the crime syndicate
right the evil version of the justice
league more or less um this is supposed
to be a six issue limited series
honestly i wouldn't be surprised if it
expanded i wouldn't be surprised if that
was the case but it's
really good if you guys aren't reading
it you guys should check it out and let
me know down in the comments if you guys
actually want me to cover it because
it's really awesome right it's not super
lengthy it's pretty quick and i'm hoping
they kind of keep it going right i'm
afraid they won't because of sales but
i'm hoping they keep it going because
it's a great concept but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace